January 23rd 2020 little did I know that
on that faithful day as I began
harmlessly uploading my very first
Dragon Ball GT review that I will be
sealing my fate for the next five months
reviewing arc after arc of Dragon Ball
GT but then having the bright idea of
reviewing Dragon Ball super with the
ambition of creating an episode where I
discuss and break down which one I
actually preferred and why week after
week after week I uploaded review after
review finally culminating with last
week 17 page long 45-minute muscle-bound
epic chronicling the entire tournament
of power all 36 episodes from beginning
to end my hands my head and my eyes hurt
but this has been some of the most fun
I've had making videos for you guys in a
very long time so before I begin this
video I want to say right from the top
thank you so so very much for watching
along for the last while it sincerely
means the world to me this week however
marks a turning point as today I will be
putting the final pin in the Dragon Ball
super story the same way I did with
Dragon Ball GT all those months ago in
this episode I will be reviewing and
breaking down everything I loved liked
and hated from Dragon Ball super I'll
also explain in places how I think it
could have been improved and at the end
I will be explaining what's next from
the battle of gods arc all the way
through the Goku black arc into the
universe survival arc this is my
impression and final review of the
series that kick-started my entire
youtube career I'm totally not mark and
this is my final review of Dragon Ball
super
[Music]
in order to effectively and thoroughly
assess my feelings on this act I will go
through every major character and I will
touch on their involvement and output in
various arcs they participated in with
each character in section I'll talk
about what I liked first and then what I
disliked so sound good
Oh also I'm not gonna touch on the
animation from the first two sagas it's
sort of low-hanging fruit and you guys
already know what I think about it given
I've covered it a number of times on
this channel already anyway first
character our main man gee the Don's the
orange key let's first discuss Dragon
Ball super z' Goku I really enjoyed the
first episode believe it or not or at
least his involvement with the first
episode let's not talk about the snake
water stuff but on a more serious note
Goku's fight against hit had something I
wish we saw more of in the series I find
her trying and in a lot of ways
succeeding and figuring out how their
opponent moved and attacked strategizing
to find a countermeasure we got to see
some stuff like that a little with the
tournament of power with Goku in his
fight against durin sort of I say sort
of because
jiren is just sort of strong so it's
just a question of needing to get better
and meet that challenge that said though
Goku's fight with hit was entertaining
and light-hearted enough for me not to
take it super seriously but also
provided enough interest for me to sink
my teeth into I also really enjoyed the
concept build-up and delivery of the
form ultra instinct I think the form was
distinct enough from Super Saiyan and
the various god forms to be its own
thing however one thing that's
interesting to me it thinks about it is
that in the ways that it is distinct
from the other forms that particular
aspect of it makes it very difficult to
age gracefully like any other
transformation would if you look back in
the series transformations like Super
Saiyan blue Super Saiyan God and
absolutely Super Saiyan have become
forms that aren't nearly as respected as
they were before because they need to
make room for new ones ultra instinct as
far as I can understand is based on
perfect combat so I'm nice like too sure
how the company can right around that
because eventually there's gonna be new
forms because there's got to be new toys
so I am interested to see how that
progresses and now what I disliked about
Dragon Ball super is Goku
stupid super Goku I've seen a lot of
discourse in the comment sections about
me labeling certain instances where Goku
acts a certain unappealing way to me as
being unfair or unjust
fight so let me explain what I mean by
stupid super Goku from the beginning of
Dragonball all the way through to the
end of the Buu saga Goku has remained
capable of being serious what he needs
to but that's not to say he always needs
or should even be serious most of the
time because him being serious
technically isn't really my issue in
fact throughout the series one of Goku's
defining character traits has been his
innocence and ability to defuse
situations that should be complicated or
tense in normal society with curiosity
and enthusiasm he shows all those
involved at certain conventions we all
abide by can be ignored for the better
whether it be his approach to snake way
his approach to training and bettering
himself in combat his interactions with
Chi Chi and his proposal at the world
tournament even meeting his son for the
first time Dragon Ball super even has
aspects that I think nailed this
particular aspect of Goku on a number of
occasions - in the universe six
tournament as everyone is bowing to Zeno
Goku treats him like he would anyone
else because he already treats everyone
the way he would like to be treated with
a friendly approach and an enthusiastic
energy to engage in the interaction I
like that I found Goku's relationship
with Zeno to be believable and it worked
for me honestly so that's not what I'm
talking about when I say stupid Super
Goku when I say that I'm talking
specific instances where Goku takes that
Goku trait of showing interest and
enthusiasm for people and changing it
into an obnoxious and irritating energy
for example when he first meets Zhu masu
contrast this to an Goku first meant
beerus in the battle of gods movie in
that he showed an excitement and an
enthusiasm for fighting beerus but he
also didn't act like a fool for floating
around him making faces in fact the
whole joke of that scene is based on
Goku trying to find a tasteful way of
making the request to fight beerus it
sounds like a subtle difference but it
manifests in a huge total shift if you
don't do it right it's the difference
between sounding innocent and sounding
like a petulant four-year-old child but
this isn't to say that it happens all
the time in Super either despite it
showing up more times than I can
tolerate for the most part Super has
produced some actually interesting
instances of dialogue with Goku - in
previous videos I've celebrated scenes
like his interaction with Frieza
bringing him back to life and when he
into the tournament with Frieza - but
when I look back on the series as a
whole I can't help but focus on
instances
the writing staff thought it was an okay
thing for him to do to forget a key part
of the plan of attack in the Goku black
arc twice let's talk about Dragon Ball
super is Gohan I liked Gohan from
episode 90 onwards and to be honest I'd
already have many issues with how he's
treated from that point up until the end
of the tournament I mean I think he has
a great balance of humility humanity and
tenacity he stays active in the
tournament for about as long as he
should his character said everything
that he needed to say and serve his team
well when all was said and done and I
pretty much said everything positive for
the character that I wanted to in the
previous video however even this aspect
of his character this section it was set
up in an incredibly unbelievable and
personally a really unsatisfying way in
addition to the vast majority of the
series demonstrating nothing new about
the character besides his adventure into
fatherhood which we barely get to see
and I don't even think I'm interested in
seeing that side of Gohan in the first
place I mean I get that the boussard to
go on has a lot of fans and so does the
great say man I just don't get the same
appeal and so you can imagine how vapid
and nothing Gohan's character was for me
personally watching the first 90
episodes of Dragon Ball super let's talk
about Vegeta in terms of stuff that I
liked his daddy Vegeta stuff with Bulma
and bulla or bra was endearing in
addition to that I enjoyed his beatdown
of Goku black for the same reasons I
liked him doing so in the prior arcs of
Z it's cathartic but there's nothing
really new there his antics trying to
distract beerus in the battle of gods
arc was good and his defense of Bulma
was sweet too but a lot of this seemed
very safe and predictable for me and
honestly the most surprising thing I
found when rewatching this series was
despite being a main character that
receives almost as much screen time as
Goku he is basically just an accessory
for Goku to set up his fights and to be
present to bounce off of
when banter needs to be made he is quite
literally Goku psychic as I said someone
to create banter with some would diffuse
with someone to take the hits of the
situation and tension becomes dire now
to be clear this wasn't something that I
disliked in the original series as
Vegeta at the time was very much a
flawed incomplete character but since
his sacrifice at the end of the Buu saga
Vegeta the character is supposed to be
better and more competent person and
usually that manifests in positive
changes for the character in the story
but
no nothing changes after coming on this
massive journey he's just as ineffective
in battle as he ever has been competent
but not effective in the long term and
because that's a large part of his charm
in fact I'd almost argue that it's a
fundamental part of his charm
there's just nothing new here in the
series for Vegeta in any meaningful way
in fact Dragon Ball super went out of
its way to revert Vegeta's character
back a few spaces when the series
actually began remember at the end of
the Buu ark when Vegeta says to goku
that he's the best or something well
while vegeta is serving beerus in the
panel of god Zarek he pretty much undoes
all of that and why because at the end
of Dragon Ball super vegeta needs to
make the decision that he's not gonna
chase Goku anymore even though he
technically already made the decision at
the end of the Buu saga which brings me
to his sacrifice in Super as big ending
this sacrifice moment in the tournament
to power I loath with every fiber of my
being I hate it as much as I hate the
piccolo sacrifice in the resurrection fr
and for the same reasons it serves no
purpose other than to rest on the hype
and ceremony created around a better
moment from the original series Vegeta
isn't making any statement of character
here it's as if they thought what made
the scene cool back in the day was how
it looked and nothing else
Vegeta doesn't get an AK of any
description in this show he doesn't try
to overcome anything we already know
he's fighting for his family we already
know he loves them and cares about other
people what made the original scene as
impactful as it was was the fact that we
didn't have a confession that Vegeta
actually did care for anyone this scene
therefore only serves to try to recreate
that same magic by changing nothing oh
but he talks about Kaaba - who cares who
actually cares about Kaaba Kaaba doesn't
even care about Kaaba that's another
thing what if the elements that super
added that I actually thought they were
gonna go somewhere with was his
relationship with Kaaba and the universe
six sands as a mentor figure but nope we
barely get anything for that I suppose
it's better to watch Goku act like a
four-year-old while jiren sleeps for a
million episodes and trust me I'm gonna
get to him but first let's talk about
beerus and weeks quickly i don't want to
spend too much time exploring beerus and
weeks because well let's face it the
show didn't either but what little we
did get to see of them in the brief
moments they did extend into the story
in meaningful ways I did enjoy quite a
bit those instances they do so really
worked in me
super feel like it's own thing and not
something only concerned with returning
and calling back to classic moments from
Z wheezes trading of Goku Vegeta at
various points in the series were
fantastic and provided some of my
favorite training moments in the entire
series I also adore wheezes character I
find him to be a strangely perfect foil
for both Goku and Vegeta
which is honestly a tough balance to try
and strike he's orderly enough to
contrast Goku and flamboyant enough to
bounce off Vegeta well he's my favorite
new character introduced into Super by a
long long way beerus unfortunately does
even less however pretty much returning
to the same story beats and gags time
and again always looking to be
uninvolved with whatever Goku and Vegeta
are doing that particular week he's
angry with Goku he's angry with Vegeta
he's angry with Goku and Vegeta sleeping
hungry heck removed that eating stuff
right there and beerus gets almost as
much screen time as Yongchun the
character has virtually nothing to do in
the story and what drew my attention to
this was actually his huh kya of Zuma
soo it wasn't a particularly intense
moment driven by story but it was still
hugely entertaining and I think it's
largely because we know he's an imposing
important character but we never
actually get to see him do anything
let's talk about his it was someone
interesting in the universe six
tournament but they really ended up
doing nothing with the character the
most noteworthy thing he did after
episode 39 was lose to Monica and then
lose to Jaron later later on he didn't
even participate in the baseball episode
when that first aired I had thought that
it was largely due to them wanting to
protect the characters mystique for the
tournament of power but he does nothing
in that either so now I ask why does hit
even exist let's talk about the masu and
Goku black
[Music]
yeah deviantART fanfiction coming to
life aside this Goku black was a really
fun character full of personality and I
get that samaithu isn't the exact same
character as Goku black but they are
both Hamas ooh
so in my mind one of two things should
have happened in this arc either both
characters should have behaved and acted
the exact same way or the differences
that existed between the characters
should have led to conflict later in the
arc between them but no either happens
and I can't be the only one that thinks
this Goku black is an entirely different
character to Zuma soo who happens to be
immortal a lot of people might explain
this away by drawing attention to how
Goku's body might have changed his
outlook and yeah okay but then why not
do something with how his character has
changed in that body
he was already powerful enough in
episode 64 to a frankly absurd degree
maybe in that arc he could have been
rubbed the wrong way by Zuma soon a few
too many times maybe he was waiting for
the right moment to dispose of Zuma soo
and when the Moffet bomb was used
against him perhaps black had the chance
to save Zuma soo but instead he goes
full scar and says long live the king
before allowing the masu to fall into
the metaphorical mouth of a gorge of
rampaging wildebeest and despite that
metaphor actually getting away from me
it still makes a lot more sense than the
entire arc so take that and speaking of
that I thought it was a really weird
choice to have this super complicated
plot about what is ultimately a really
really simple story trunks is timeline
is in trouble they need to get the bad
guys out and despite that simple story
in order to make even the most humble of
attempts to make sense of all of this
you need a tall glass of coffee a wide
open schedule at a corkboard with a
million intersecting strings and guess
what it still doesn't make sense even if
you do that let's talk about Freeza
Freeza is without reservation the best
character in Dragon Ball super don't at
me and it's not even a contest granted
he's not in it a lot and maybe that's
part of the appeal for me but from the
moment Cooke who recruits him up until
the very end and even beyond that into
the bro Lee movie Frieza enhances each
and every scene he participates in and
even in scenes he's not in I swear
towards the ending of the tournament of
power I was waiting for him to show up
and do something crazy in a positive way
I mean and that's another sign of a
character that adds to a show on top of
that again freeze a story in the
universe survival arc begins as someone
who would hop on to any other team that
got the first signing of a better deal
if
initially coming to terms with his trust
issues at the end of the arc it's
compelling stuff producing for me
throughout his time in the tournament
great moment after moment easily the
star of the show for me but we're
finally here let's talk about Dragon
Ball super zeroD for the first 90% of
the universe survival arc Durin's arc is
a beautiful story of how a fencepost
became a character I wrote a video
talking about your an in-depth that I
think you should watch if you haven't or
are interested but in short he doesn't
work for the story this arc is trying to
tell I think personally but I have more
to add to that along with I think an
explanation but before I get to that
people have been commenting on my last
video addressing my people are flying
comments by saying well actually if you
really account for all the variables
that the so-called flying you're
referring to in the tournament of power
could be accounted for with a series of
complex physics based explanations oh
yeah well what about this explain that
but even the flying aside that honestly
isn't even the first or even the last
issue I had with Joran as a character he
just does stuff and then doesn't for
ages the universe survival arc if you
really boil it down is just a collection
of really cool moments but there isn't a
story like the other tournaments in
Dragon Ball have had as I've said I've
enjoyed isolated moments from this
series pockets of brilliance and as you
saw in the last video I address
everything I really enjoyed which
happened to climax well with the final
of three episodes of the series but
despite those episodes working in
isolation in a vacuum the real problems
the arc itself faces become much more
evident the farther back you stand from
the problem because as a story the arc
itself is flawed on a fundamental level
and suffers from severe bloating at
times in unnatural ways I sincerely
believe now after going back over the
series that the driving force behind the
story and pacing issues plaguing the
series is most certainly not the lack of
effort or imagination at the studio but
in fact a lack of a solid foundation or
source from which to establish or create
a story upon what Akira Toriyama is very
much in charge of dictating the story of
the series what he gives to the studios
and Toyo taro in terms of material to
work with
is completely unknown it's obvious to me
at least that both Joey and Toyo Terra
with his manga embellish and deviate
from the notes of akira toriyama when
the opportunity presents itself this is
most obvious given that both make very
different choices with the story yet
intersect at a number of key points
before ending in the same place keeping
that in mind I think it's somewhat
telling when looking back at the animes
final arc episode list notice anything
different between this and all the other
arcs
anybody how about the fact that it's
over twice as long as the second longest
and four times longer than the others
and if you notice all the arcs of super
that appear in the manga also are longer
and more bloated than the mangas version
which doesn't have to deal with a
specific pressure the anime does and
this pressure I think is the main
driving force behind why the anime feels
so bloated and boring in certain parts
and that pressure is timeslots Dragon
Ball super ended its three-year stint on
Fuji TV on March 25th 2018 however the
universe survival arc tend to be the
climax of the series was announced in
2016 and ran for over thirteen months
this is simply an observation of mine
but while the final arc of super has the
most story to tell I still believe the
writers and producers of the show were
faced with a crisis of story a problem
of trying to fit a square block into a
circular hole they had a story provided
by accurate or Yama but in its current
state would not bring them to the finish
line of March 25th and so then we were
greeted with seven episode long stints
where jaren the goal of the tournament
sleeps and stands on the sidelines doing
nothing this would explain why so much
emphasis was put on two characters in
the tournament that ultimately went
nowhere and this also explains why the
tournament felt less like a story and
more like a filler tastic monster of the
week type series with every universe in
the tournament falling to universe
sevens efforts and no other universe
ever leading to a subsequent universe's
demise
not even the great cheerin was able to
eliminate a single universe heck even
the manga at least doesn't share that
problem and I have a host of reasons not
to enjoy that telling too but in saying
this however assuming my theory is
correct I think what toy did to fill the
time was somewhat well done well the
story from start to finish doesn't flow
well the series of many moments worked
well individually however in saying that
the level of disorganized storytelling
ruin the journey for me created the
unlikely circumstances that led to the
universe seven wrecking everyone which
is akin to a single rest are knocking
out everyone in a battle royal and if
you're going to portray the universe
seven team as the underdogs maybe don't
frame them like that while also having
them wreck every other universe but that
brings me to the future my plan is
moving forward as it stands these last
few months have retaken it out of me and
so I plan on tackling singular videos
for a little while before moving on to
my next big review series and don't
worry there will be another one I've
seen your comments and I will be
returning with another series soon thank
you so much for the support once again
my name is totally nut mark I'll see you
guys next week and thank you so much for
watching
you